e
really quite a story
really
okay limiting uh redisclosure consumer
reports for question and
connection
okay so
um uh I I might know notes this we were
going to in inter room study this
motion so uh there are any mortgage
brokers here anyone who cares about this
bill okay as I told you last is said
they need to be giving a piece of paper
when they to ask person you know to fill
out the disclosure and say by the way
you know you might get a lot of crap in
the mail or the phone and whatever so be
sure you call this 800 number whatever
it was and get online and and make sure
tell if the feds take care of it that's
great but I in the meantime I urge you
to use this uh this problem as an
opportunity for you guys to Spread
spread that word but I realize you're a
lobbyist and not one of them so who
knows who knows how far that message
will get but it's on
YouTube
Okay okay
so 3:32 yes I'm looking for someone to
it committee okay represent
spear oh yeah what committee are we
doing here oh yeah that's good point is
list we
got you have the list no the list of
who's on the subcommittee there's your
sube I'm
in
okay you can Circle okay so we
have spear on holy moly there's a lot of
you're on
Ammon Ammon
Maier Herbert he's here grass grassy is
C grass's got bigger
fish and spear okay so spear you're on
you're
good yes all right so represents oh I'm
sorry we're just going to S get get
the uh then we have no then we have yeah
we have at the end of the
day
so okay and then we have Property and
Casualty back to Insurance okay all
right representative spear seconded by
representative Ammon moves uh interim
motion
yes I'm sorry I I didn't hear hear some
of what you were saying why is it inm
study
versus um you can't this is you know the
enforcement is huge huge problem this is
an opt in uh rather than an opt
out uh and that there is an opt out
process that anybody can choose and you
just have to go online and and say
please don't sent me your junk
mail are we talking about 3:32 yes
uh seemed like it was a good bill uh in
that case if you're just going to is it
I shouldn't be the one that make the
motion I could see that
all right is the motion clear so who do
we need replacement to need so if tax's
not here grass is so they can't each
no
pus pusk are you on this one no no he's
so he's here he could you need a
set no wait how manys do you
pass yes
R I think there was some discussion
around what age was appropriate but I
think 16 seems to be a good a good 16 I
mean I G I made sure when my kids had a
car that yeah they needed they needed a
credit card to get gas you know they
need you know so and to me 16 is
definitely the right age
everybody
okay all right is there any discussion
on the motion of a to pass question yes
representative Herbert what is the uh
age what is the age is there an age
okay all those in favor say I I all
yep okay Senate Bill 334 providing for
issuance of bonds and other obligation
by the business fin
Authority so it's Nea was the old name
for the um student
loans and the only reason I know that is
they're now the new one is advertising
on or on NPR and they said formerly Nea
that's
it
remember
okay uh all right who would like to make
buros yeah this is the bond it's not any
obligation to the state you don't know
it just these they made available
and okay any discussion on the
motion yeah is this new the um I think
they came in here and talked about these
uh bonds yeah it just it's it's just
changing from different institutions
that are going to be doin all right this
Bond
good okay all those in favor please
raise your hand one two one two three
four five
six
okay
and continuing our winning streak here
477 commission review and make
recommendations regarding Technology
based startup businesses support from
the state of New Hampshire okay now
here's what this is going to be a fun
one all right who is willing to serve on
this
commission I
would you are I would do we need four
okay but I think there's it's not going
to work it's not it's I think interim
study is the way to go you don't interim
study a study committee a commission
well we need to we need to make what I I
don't want to kill this because I think
it's an opportunity for tech companies
to be able to access grant funding if we
make an effort to um support the tech
Alliance in this initiative I think this
committee Commerce Committee I think
needs to it it it requ as money at the
end of the day they're looking for money
so there is federal
money there is federal money and there
is the Innovative fund that the state um
funds every year you should have your
mic on the Innovation fund right every
year they put they matching FS different
aren't they matching funs yeah that's
fine that's fine you really think we're
going to cough up with matching funds
through the Innovation funds depends
which party wins in November there's
there's always there's always moneyone
you're going to want to use the money to
fund education you're not going to want
to give it to high tech companies right
now it's supporting healthcare
workers next year it can support you
know the tech Alliance
or I don't know I I don't want to kill
it because I think we're we're take
we're not I I think we can get some
federal money we somehow like I say you
you between now and next Tuesday when we
ex this okay you need to find three
other members of the committee who are
willing to be on it okay and then
otherwise otherwise I'm not going to
pass something if nobody wants to be on
it she's she's tagged she's it well the
Republicans don't want to pay for
anything so I mean that's the
problem um okay all right so uh we will
and I will talk to the um the people
that came in to speak in theal the tech
Alliance I will talk to them about the
Mission and look to see if there's you
know if we can minimize moves to
motion
yep all
right and like I say I will ask I'll be
posing that question at exec and if we
don't have people want to do it then you
know why why why set up a you know
because I don't know about you on your
side but on our side will be here in the
chairman Vice chairman meeting is is
there are too many commissions and get
three months too I mean it wasn't a
lengthy I think I like I said I think if
we I know by the time you get all the
appointments it's the time I don't think
I think we can just meet for okay maybe
once or twice and then we'll come up
with some
legislation okay is the motion clear
have to pass all those in favor say I I
one two
three one two three
four yes okay all those opposed one
two okay that's four to two
y okay all right all right now now we're
ready for some fun Senate Bill
97 use of animal products
testing I think we should uh interim
study this bill
there is an amendment right do we have
an amendment where do I put
online what's that it was was yeah
somebody emailed it to me can I get it
from Carrie right it was does she have
it from this is yeah this is from
Gina yeah yes it's from Gina
Gina what motion are you putting I I
think we should just interum study the
bill and sort this thing out in terms of
you know what what exactly is
Dartmouth Dartmouth and UNH doing to
animals but the maybe they're doing mice
things you know who knows what they're
doing there's a bigger problem with it
there's no enforcement there's no
nothing no yeah the enforcement entity
was was hugely problematic right that
that
didn't I'm not going that VI Justice
that was
recommended
right so in inter study we would just
we'll work on it this you know and see
if there's some way we can get there
so so you're going to be working on it
during the summer so what I interim
study interim study we won't I don't
September September October but no I
don't plan to come up from rhod Island
the only time I've ever had to do that
was was study you know study
commissions and I was not always a happy
camper because it's a three-hour Drive
yeah
welome my world yeah
right okay who would like to make the
inter room study
spear any discussion on the
motion I'm against
it you want you want to okay you're
against the inter room study you're
against the inter room study motion yeah
what what motion would you like I mean
what do you favor kill it pardon me what
do you want to do with this bill if we
don't interim
study we'll do an interim study I guess
you know but I I'm going to be outvoted
so but I'm just why what would you
rather what would be the motion you want
did you want to pass it or did you want
to kill it I would rather pass it than
kill it all right okay so interim study
interim
study okay the motion clear all right
all those in favor of inum study raise
your hand 1 2 3
4 am I missing someone one two
three four five okay and all
we have the fire marshall here
today okay so I have a question for you
bill
bill okay in this build
no
uh about please cuz there's there's a in
Europe it's
LTV is another standard that's not a
UL are you familiar with that it's the
European equivalent to the UL standard
for the United States yeah it's are you
familiar with that I'm not familiar with
it so I'm Brian Allard the assistant
director with the Fire Marshals office
Marshall Tumi couldn't be here today
okay I know he did submit the written
testimony if you support of this but I'm
not familiar with that particular
standard and you're
saying I saw he he he's unfamiliar okay
but as I read the bill
now it
says any
personal
by and this is part of a complete
electrical system yeah so it's it's
saying it only is accepting Underwriters
that's the problem that's where we're a
little concerned because if it's made in
China it might not have the underwriters
certificate on it it might have the the
European the European one um I know the
most of the legislation across the
United States right now is referencing
the UL uh standards um and that's kind
of what our position has been right
along okay and then and uh enforcement
how was this going to be
enforced this is just if you happen to
stumble upon one of these you
yeah we're certainly take it away from
the
person not sure we we've certainly had
um buyers within the state that
potentially could have been uh due to a
non listed device uh we have not been
able to pinpoint that specifically um
but certainly there there's a big push
out in New York City specifically for
the UL standards uh because there's been
several fires
okay representative spear the iso stands
for international standards organization
and it's ISO
23625 colon
2021 for lithium batteries every country
acknowledges those those isos right but
that's not in this bill yeah we and
that's what we should have in the bill
we going to amend it you want to amend
this bill to add
yeah we said we going to do that Ed the
iso standard yeah because everybody
knows those
right
okay okay
um
so we need an amendment uh we would need
an
amendment oneliner I guess she just just
ISO is all we needed to add well you say
ISO you could say that the specific ISO
standard yeah well which is what they
did with the UL yeah just add the iso
standard and then that will pick up
everybody because that's an
international
standard but you don't want to you know
maybe uh do you want do you want to go
down to legislative services today to uh
get an amendment I don't know how to do
that but I I'll show you I'll sure can I
just sure okay representative Ammon uh
this seems to be we call prophylactic
legislation it it doesn't seem to be
backed by actual data that that's my
concern um because New York City's doing
it that's a very populated place you
know with uh high-rise buildings and you
know it's we don't have we're more rural
arees in Manchester there's a few I
wouldn't call them
highrise so I I'd be before enter and
studying this bill that that would be my
position
but representative Barrow yeah I just
want to say know I don't have obviously
you know I don't have specific data but
um I read the Times and there have been
numerous stories there was one pretty
recently about a month ago of people
dying because the they had had their
bicycles in their apartment and um it
was it was really tragic recently a
young man I think he was like 28 um died
um when his bike caught fire and it was
an apartment building it could have
really and and there have been numerous
stories about that and I when I last
thing when I went on um an airplane
recently I had I had a suitcase brand
that has a battery one of those
batteries and she said is your battery
in the suitcase and I had to tell her
that I I took it out right they wouldn't
let it on the planes so right no I know
the airlines are very very tough about
so there's a reason they do that so but
but that's begs the question that it
whether it had the standard on it
already and it was just a malfunctioning
battery yeah but if I always heard the
the the number one problem is
overcharging that people plug leave it
plugged in and they don't they don't
unplug it and it overcharges and that's
what causes the or should we interim
study it I would prefer to interim study
it make sure we really do this right
okay yes I would prefer that is
everybody okay within room study yep
okay so just what we need is a little
more detail on how it terms of other um
certifications all right and how that
certification is supposed to work um and
and and mean I we certainly are not
opposed to the concept that we want to
make sure that we don't have any
fraudulent lithium batteries out there
but at the same time we're you we
haven't had really any evidence that
that is the problem was that there was
they were fake ones or someone I don't
know I don't know how do you make a fake
or whatever you do but but I guess we
need to know how how we're going to do
that uh structure that and and before we
put it in our statutes okay very good
thank you okay so we don't need it don't
need the
Ammon second by representative burough
study any discussion on the
motion all right all those in favor say
I I one two three four five six okay
just can I just say I just looked up um
online there according this there have
been
25,000 uh fires caused by these
batteries over a 5year period right but
does it say anything about whether
they whether they were fakes or whether
knows chairman hunt yes it's counterfeit
it can be counterfeit batteries so it
still have the the sticker on it yeah
you're right yeah it could be a
counterfeit battery and still have the
sticker on
it all right so we do I yeah that's why
we need to do little more homework on
that
build okay uh okay moving right along
um
515 consumer guaranteed contracts excuse
me did you vote on that
uh yes we did okay six to zip inter room
study inter room
study which one 55 you okay with that no
36 okay yeah we thought we already voted
okay we did okay okay guar consumer
guaranteed contract that's funny I put
it here as because that's it's almost
it's really an insurance
bill in reality I put it in the wrong
category bad me okay all right uh uh I
assume we're all happy no amendments
right we're everybody's everybody's all
happy happy with this one okay uh who
would like to make the
motion any right Cole so Cole and here
pass any discussion on the
motion all those in favor say I I those
opposed
the
moovly
okay all right here we go to the next
here's the next exciting one uh
restricting the purchase of real
property on and around military
installations okay who would like to
make the interim study motion interim
study that we're going to kill it you
want to kill
it you guys really yeah me too all
right
chines okay
what it is true we have we already have
a China
bill that we a house one that we we
inter we did inter so that would that
would give a reason why we wouldn't
bother inter studing this one because
we're already getting I just think it
sends a message how bad it was what itl
yeah one of one of the problems is it
says relative restricting the purchase
of real property on or around military
installations and then it goes on to
list a whole lot of other things that
have nothing not just military it's it's
it it read this phrase right after it it
says uh
structural structural but that's the
point it's not it's not a bill about
military I was okay as long as they said
something about military just as a
Feelgood but it got into everything did
you see the email birel sent that's or
did she send it to me anything really
use well she said the guy North Dakota
had passed it and they had they didn't
have any problems with it in north OTA
and I go well isn't North Dakota where
they have all those missile sites isn't
that where that woman who killed her dog
as
Governor
okay but but the idea yeah B choice so
but the big problem I had was the
testimony was was that if you are if if
you are a Chinese People's Republic
citizen
that means you are part of the
government because you're that's and but
that was the testimony so that was where
I got hung up on whereas you know am I
I'm G to ask you know someone any who
from who's from China you know whether I
was going to rent them to my vacation
rental and she says oh yeah another
South North Dakota doesn't have that
problem sure there's a lot of vacation
rentals in North Dakota but not
withstanding that but I just don't I
just just don't know if that bill was
written the same way as this one was
this one this one seemed like a non
struggle thing that did happen as a
result of that incident in North Dakota
was that the United States government
now says that if any if a if a chinese
firm wants to buy land within a 100
miles of a military base they have to
ask for permission from the federal
government if it's approved then they
can go buy whatever they want right so
at that point it's a federal issue as
far as security is concerned and that I
have quite a bit of knowledge about okay
this thing does nothing with respect to
security
so it's in conflict with the Federal
Regulation and it doesn't have anything
security okay all
right yeah oh R guys are having a good
conversation and I'm listening okay but
the fact you just have to yell at me and
say you want to speak
okay um but there there is federal
legislation in effect now that puts some
restrictions on the sale of property
uh if it's within a 100 miles of a
military
base they have to ask for
permission then the feds say yes no and
then they can sell whatever they want or
buy the land or whatever yeah I thought
Nikki Haley got reamed because she sold
a bunch of land right next to him
military no they didn't sell it they
bought
it South Carolina who bought oh in South
Carolina I'm sorry South Carolina that
they it was a there there was she
did take help for having having the
South Carolina but to them it was an
economic development issue they were all
very excited about having you know
having that that Chinese company come to
to South Carolina and right
notwithstanding the fact that it was too
close to a military China owns a bunch
of stuff in the United States tick Tok
too you know yeah no but I mean they
built a a multi-billion dollar uh pipe
facility in
Texas uh McConnell sold some property in
his
state but uh so I don't I I think it's
very difficult problematic but I'm anti
I'm anti-pry anyway
so China is the 18th if you count who
owns the most land according to Forbes
Magazine it's the
18th owner number one is Canada
Netherlands Saudi Arabia is in there
Iran is in there where do we draw the
line I mean they're 18th they don't own
that much but they do own businesses and
they have as part of our
economic stability for this country uh
we encourage foreign investments we have
foreign investments on everything and
they are a partner of ours they're a big
partner actually we buy a lot of our
exports you know so I just I just was
laws okay I think we're the
consensus is itl yes it is so
representative spear second by
okay the motion
clear all those in favor say I I those
uh okay you know the scanning of non-
drivers identification card by real
yeah so this one yeah so you pull up
says no no we're talking about making an
so this is for people that don't drive
and have IDs who don't have a Auto
ID relatively SK non drivers IDs cars so
is cuz
I mean because you have after the
closing cell you it it's a very short
period of
time and and I'm okay with breaking the
law real ID so that's that's a driver's
license
dri you don't driver you can get an ID a
regular ID a real ID okay I did it with
my driver's license I think wants to
make the motion
about
change
uh you can get a real ID without a
and then B in the bill in the actual
language of the bill yes so we don't we
don't amend the title the title gets
um the license holders consent to okay
yeah yeah so that that would that the
title would be corrected by legislative
services
and so what happened
is
that is if actually you look at the the
bill does it show what the bill as as uh
introduced if you go in that was the
only version but it does say Amendment
or that oh these are just searings yes
no Amendment that's introduced okay yeah
so they they just screw up but yes I
think that's what it is we'll make we'll
make sure that they correct the right
the title right but the title doesn't
mean anything right okay the analysis is
correct yeah yeah the title the title
disappears after it'll be in the in the
actual
um what do they call that yellow
book is there such a thing as a
non but they'll usually they'll have it
corrected but you can get an ID
ners yeah well I'm saying it it because
it's just another set of eyes so should
we make sure it is in one way or
another Kristen yeah so just make sure
legislative Services
is knows that they need to correct the
title driver's
license it say it yeah just it's it just
remove the
non only it is yeah because the analysis
say license good catch so the people
with a non ID can't do something in real
estate I mean I
don't well I mean I know for myself then
when my I we took my mother's car away
from her and came time for license
renewal we just when I went to the
register they they asked um they said
they said now this was the best part
they said so um okay so you know we
can't renew the you know you don't want
to renew the license so you're going to
have to get you get an ID
and it looks just like a license oh and
it just it says non- driver's license so
that's where the non- driver expression
comes from and he goes so not meanwhile
she's she's in a nursing home right and
he goes I said well do you have anything
to prove what her address is and the
best I could do was the church
bulletin was coming to her that add
dress in the church bolon and he looked
at he looked at that he looked at me he
okay real estate workers
so okay where uh where am I on this my
oh okay there we go five okay um all
right so for for now I'll put my name in
May we're thinking thaon might want to
make this motion but
um ought to
pass
yep any discussion on the
motion okay all those in favor say I I
those
opposed
okay so all we have left is this
afternoon are
these so these are uh
chairman yes can we just do 196 because
the the sponsor wants it
itl
yeah soci said it was overcome by events
remember right right but that that's the
insurance committee
subcommittee so let's just do it it's
itl I know I know everybody wants it
have it yeah we'll get toed for at 115
we technically can't me in in hindsight
I I probably should have scheduled all
these it just seemed like so many bills
and subcommittee I just and I and I I
you know I always have to calculate for
some of them getting getting bogged down
on well that one wouldn't and and you
know we had I had you know we had a
couple bogged down you know lithium and
and uh well now we just sit around China
so okay so so far we got no reason to we
can do everything we're aiming for
Tuesday at 10 this point I'm
sorry to EXA Tuesday at 10 unless we
afternoon you talking about next Tuesday
yeah so but and actually uh
representative MCU he he didn't want he
he had he had a um
a county meeting
it
anytime precedent for this committee
next Tuesday we talking about right next
yeah
e
okay so open up the
subcommittee uh property casually here
we got uh first
up minimum amount of uninsured Motors
coverage okay yes this itl
so uh so who's on the insurance
committee all right so who wants to make
the motion to kill this
bill since that's what the sponsor us to
do
rep right so collabro has been replaced
by
rafner and Vincent well you're gonna
take
grass and Vincent is no longer on the
committee did we we replace any ter and
they canel children around and ter and V
that's right so they can't right so
that's right
that's it so we got we got U Peli and
Hunt rafner Gibbs and Burrows Gibbs is
replacement this is Insurance oh this is
buiness no this is we're down we're
Insurance property casually okay all
right
uh yeah the sponsor told us to go ahead
it well technically it's
Gibbs but is spear replace Gibbs okay
there okay right just two demat right no
no it's three
Democrats you got rafner oh Raptor okay
got it okay that's that's your okay and
that's for the rest of that's the rest
of the day we do have a couple we have
two liquor ones at the end okay who
would like to make the motion of
itl okay thank
you
okay
okay all
right uh so yeah so rafter you make the
second I'm Sor I make the motion to itl
sb1 196 okay any discussion on the
motion of in expedi to legislate seeing
none all those in favor raise your hand
one two three
second what that second it uh Raptor
okay okay so yeah
spear okay all right six is zip
yeah right all those all those yeah
those unanimous
okay okay uh all right who would like to
kill the next one 325 who would like to
motion 196 is yeah 196 inexpedient to
legislate now we're on
325 and I'm asking who would like to
are you on this committee okay
creating you are you're replacing Gibbs
y okay all right I I'll make the
motion oh you want to make the motion
yeah
and second by repres car okay yes in
exped to legislate um there's no reason
to create a licensing for
appraisers it's
anyways John Hunt's rule of lure
remember we only reason we create a
license is so we can take it away from
you when you've been bad you take it
too you like doctor's licenses uh he's
the one who said he doesn't like
licensing don't get don't throw me into
that
H yes I think that we create that
license so that we can take it away when
you
when you're bad surgeon so
okay uh all right so the motion is
inexpedient to legislate
uh all those in favor say I two three
four five six all those oppose so moved
unanimously
okay now now we get to the fun one okay
uh
423 relative to mandatory disclosure of
insurance policy limits representative
spear I can make a motion to itl it but
I'd like to make a comment yes no you
can you can then speak to your motion
representative spear moves uh to
inexpedient to legislate second by
representative hunt and see the value of
some of these things as you know as we
heard in the hearing but the problem I
have is the same problem that I have
with the right to no
bill there's no definition of claimant
there's no definition of who is allowed
to apply for
anybody's uh insurance coverage and I
think that's an an opportunity for for
the bill to be taken serious advantage
of so beside the Privacy issue I think
that this is just going to cause a whole
lot of problems
could could we tweak it we talked about
an
amendment how how would you tweak it I
thought we were talking we have an
amendment on it no I know we talked
about the possibility of just limiting
it to claimants as yeah but there's no
definition of claimants well can we do
both if you want to otherwise I just get
rid of
it do you really want to tell how much
Insurance to a trial
order before they even decided case you
know you want them to know how much
insance you
have that's just it the potential for
great okay you put it that
way well that's the only way I know
umbrella
so
actually okay
all right so the motion is inex being to
legislate any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor say I I
those opposed so moov
hunt Okay and now we're on to
liquor so we have a different
subcommittee
I thought we I thought we passed more P
more than I normally would pass yeah
yeah but but it's theoretically these
bills all been through one body already
right and then when you start think when
you start looking at itls of bills that
went through the Senate you go what the
going well they don't do their homor
the yeah we probably don't want to get
into this discussion do not do motives
of the other side you just threw them
under the
bus under the bus I threw them under the
bus we'll have to see how much insurance
they
have looks like we need one
Democrat V okay so we have Pusa C was
post we end up doing
so Vincent I think Vincent he was on
this too who do we who do we replace
with
un there's there's only seven you're
collabor right you replace
your
um I am too
[Music]
right right so we'll
justt is he lier he's not here no who
else right so okay we have who the other
ones I
today he he might have been no grassy
banking I don't know what I did okay
you're you're on tag you're it okay
uh 137 the Nano Nano Bill okay
representative
pusc second by representative
willo okay you could do Sullivan yes oh
yeah you want to you want to get credit
okay this one
put thank you Mr chair okay you want to
speak to your motion yes I will I move
OTP on uh Senate Bill 137 FN repeals the
Nano Brewery license and opens up the uh
laws to the 21st
century and makes us more competitive
uh okay sounds good anyone any
discussion on the motion about to pass
see none all those in favor say I those
unanimously and last but not
least establishing a commission to study
the marketing of ecigarettes and E
Liquids
33 um we have an
amendment and we have an amendment I
is
it
um Kristen did you is there an
electronic version of this
I
can you
go
history I can do a quick difference it
says the whole bill
so the membership of the study group is
different the amendment proposes one
Senator or three House
compensation same compensation
for the committee shall consult with the
Department of Revenue and the Liquor
Commission as well as stakeholders and
[Music]
orig we're we're just going over what
was changed in the amendment Senate
member the
chair was the chair yeah say right there
shall be called by first name Senate
member this is too vague okay the
meeting put it on the
1711 okay and then it's a committee not
a commission oh it's a comme it's a
committee aiss not a commission because
commissions
or boo no
NOS
okay yeah it looks good to me yeah you
guys do you get a copy of it here would
mine so this is the issue is
how how the
taxation um we got we got to create a
better system because one person is
paying 20 6% of the the taxes collected
and and yes he's got a dozen stor of
locations but he he really should be uh
should be a fraction of the overall
sales and that uh evidently uh it's a
it's a free-for-all and how this product
is coming into New Hampshire unlike
tobacco which goes through wholesalers
and we regulate them we license them
right don't we license those
wholesalers so be be prepared that the
the end end product is going to be a
lure of anybody who is wholesaling in
New Hampshire I think that's a good
idea and I I assume that's what other
states are doing
so no but say the cigarettes is already
wholesalers they're already in the
business this is this is just going to
obviously we're going to try to capture
who we're going to try to handle the
same thing but I mean that's face it
that's the same thing with
liquor and you know and beer and you
know I mean that's John Hunt's rule of
lure that's why we have it when it comes
to you know it comes to collecting
attacks you you got to license it you
got to regulate it and then you can
collect the tax have a better system
streaming of who's paying the tax so you
know the it is interesting to note that
one of the uh beer distributors uh uh
things that they hold out as being why
they s serve an important purpose is
that they are the ones that are
collecting the beer
tax the state and and they actually have
it written in the statute that um when
they deliver the beer the tax has to be
paid within 15 days so nobody caring
carrying carrying that and and uh which
is a very interesting statute when you
think about
it
right no it's still 15 days yeah
days why don't you come over the mic and
question thank you chairman committee
members uh Lieutenant Matt Culver from
New Hampshire State Liquor Commission um
and thank you for the question the uh
part of the statute that was changed
last year representative was when the
taxes were
due yeah so right 17913 is the limited
Credit Law and and the chairman is
correct that's uh 15 days
after uh the product is sold to retail
those invoices are paid to the
wholesalers and then the wholesalers pay
the commission on a monthly basis of
that 30 cents a gallon for that re that
sale so yes so representative spe has a
question and it may be directed at you
uh it it says that section two of this
bill which sets up the commission uh
takes effect November 1st
2024 that's a couple of days before the
election so what does that mean in in
practical sense we're going to stand up
a committee and then they all go away
because they got
[Laughter]
unelected
when when the election is
over you are
still a State Rep until the 1 of January
Wednesday of
December that's when we get sworn in and
answer believe it or not okay so we have
to whatever is going to happen with this
the commission has to happen before
December
7th
right like I say my expectation is that
we will be busy working ahead of
time to uh review other states and the
lure process and how we want to set it
up so by the time this commission is
appointed we'll already have a proposal
for for the commission to be looking at
and then we'll get buyin from house memb
senate members so that that will be able
that good all right so the motion uh
representative
[Music]
moves ought to pass on the amendment
number
1711 any
discussion see none all those in favor
say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously representative
pusk second by representative buroughs
moves ought to pass as amended
motion good seeing none all those in
favor say I I I those opposed so moved
unanimously and Commerce Committee is
done
right we bring a whole new definition to
yeah
e